[Music]
everybody V Colton 360 live pre-show
starts now guys welcome to the conan 360
live pre-show presented by AT&T
I'm your host Moses storm and now Chris
red we're live to you right now from the
roof of the Spreckels theater for the
international event known as cama can
con all right whatever close enough okay
today we're gonna be counting down to
the actual Conan show where he's gonna
welcome special guests from the new
movie bright ya Will Smith Noomi Rapace
a bunch of other surprise guests and we
got the cast from Supernatural right and
their demons and their demons and on
this live show we're also gonna sit down
with the creators of Harley Quinn I'm
talking about Paul Dini yeah Jimmy
palomito and Amanda Connor I think
Amanda has a surprise for us special
sketch drawing I'm looking forward to
that we also have a special interview
going inside the mind of associate
sociopath producer Torrence olanski
which definitely sounds like a white
murderer
that's right Jordan shlonsky has all the
charm and warmth of a stone found at the
bottom of the ocean and of course we're
gonna take a look inside the Batman vs
Superman I guess it's a virtual reality
tour we're gonna see that but this is
actual tour that happens on the Warner
Brothers lot I guess you could get
tickets for now yeah he'll get those
tickets also we're gonna have an
exclusive tour Kona's office by no other
than conan himself baby that's right and
you know this is the first year that
we're doing a 360 live pre-show and I
just want to assure the audience at home
that this is going to have everything
that you love about live streaming show
that's exactly right man of course
talking about harsh transitions or
really sweaty hosts that have nothing to
wipe the sweat off with and audio issues
between the hosts Chris I understand
you're down at the artists entrance
what's the vibe like down there I do not
what hell for lunch Thanks and of course
I'm talking about host throwing to media
clips that the producers do not have
with that being said let's throw to this
clip of a frog Duncan Oh Michael
Jordan's face well I hear that that clip
is not on the show because it doesn't
on earth yes much like any area on this
roof that is below 114 degrees it does
not exist I am sweating in places I
can't say LTV and of course we can have
everyone's favorite part of a live show
dead air and of course the whole show is
brought to you in 360 and I want you
guys to encourage you guys to really
scroll around and see everything use
your SW da keys to look around if you
get those VR goggles because you didn't
pay rent yeah use those to look around
and check out our definitely haunted set
see you can see anything man if you want
to know is this grass real scroll down
and look at it
its turf the cousin 360 live show is
we're gonna be checking in with unmanned
cams yeah all around there and then we
gonna be down the lobby playing games
and in surprise guests like you never
know who's gonna run up on us you know
never know the coning 360 live show is
great for anyone who's been watching the
Conan show and thought wish you saw less
of Conan and more of the craft service
gentlemen how are you sir thank you see
you Moses Chris how's it going it's good
yeah this is exciting you have your own
little Tiki lounge yes top of a random
roof yes I have very sexy mystery plants
on my shirt that's not good
that's not good listen I want to
congratulate you both and thank you for
doing this this is an excuse me thank
you for doing this this is incredible
the conan 360 pre-show yeah we came up
with our name ourselves it was nice do
you like it we love it and we love our
FEMA provided Tiki Ted yes it's very
nice and your face is everywhere do you
ever get tired of no it always seems
just right it's what I always dreamed of
my face everywhere it's what I always
saw when I was a child I saw my face
everywhere right and then rather than
have that corrected yeah
through therapy and medication I just
went and got famous you know that was
just the idea follow your dreams people
now it was the first you have a bad
dream if you have like a bad dream right
follow it just get a conventional job
most of you shouldn't follow your dreams
right that's like that's that's great
advice most of you are not good at this
was my dream and I immediately regret it
you know one of the reasons that you
guys were selected is that when we got
this theater and rented it they were up
here already doing a show on the roof
yeah we were they were here
most of
a podcast ring magicians on it does not
translate Oh terrible
you gotta fool but we thought let's just
build a sort of Gilligan's Island hut
around you which we did you excited we
have a great lineup today I am so
excited man I'm excited to be able to
guess I'm gonna fans that are outside
waiting for a long time very smelly cuz
they've been waiting since yesterday yes
you know showers outside of there aren't
showers in there they tend to be in
cosplay and those are very they've been
wearing those I think they usually put
their costume on a month before Comic
Con and they drive up I saw a lot of
people in cosplay for Will Smith in the
pursuit of happiness
that's a weird choice just an
ill-fitting dirty suit and I would be
honest with the people I just I just
realized what cosplay was I thought it
was something else I cannot say on TV
listen I don't like where you're going I
don't like where you were okay let's
stick with where I am right now in the
moment I'm very excited Will Smith
coming tonight this with the entire cast
of bright bright alleging anybody here
it's gonna be fantastic
amazing cast and then guess who's coming
second supernatural guys that's a big
show that show's been on for 15 years
it's the biggest show in North America
that was I don't even know what that
means always says biggest show in North
I know I don't know original back no now
let me I see something which way can we
walk Dwight any way around because we
were acting like it was a conventional
camera right and we are setting this up
in 60 so I'm here then is that the idea
that's the idea Thome hit your mark
think I just saw it now and we don't
waste of everyone's time
anyway that's not here you look insane
so so I shouldn't have stayed over there
is that what you're saying well now
you're not gonna want to see that
footage all right this is cool right
doesn't it feel like we're about to
fight the audience at home really feel
like credible technology and amazing
technologies guys you're getting paid
how's this work um not getting paid they
left a hot case of Fanta up here yep you
know and the warm burritos with no meat
in it okay and they also lock the doors
as soon as your shows where are we
putting you up because I'm at a really
nice hotel where are you guys we're
staying at the beige Westin in and the
she airs that Macy's that's a store yep
are you talking about I'm just dead
you're just hanging out in a display I
haven't prepared
do you realize what I have to go through
before every show makeup hair makeup
full body wax first okay oh then they
have to simulate human flesh color on my
face that's what that's that color yeah
you guys met me yesterday and I didn't
have makeup on when you were freaked out
you look like a real dead yeah it's like
you coached t-ball and then you look
like you also wanted to be thrown into
the game
yeah oh no he's wearing shorts that was
like they was those are deadly swim
trunks at one time that's not true okay
maybe they were yes and that's an improv
rule stick to that fight for your dreams
listen is improv you can definitely
finish the classes but anything beyond
that yeah just finish the classes but
then don't get into comedy it's mostly a
nightmare there's too many people I mean
you guys I mean this is one of them
you're at the top 1% yeah and you're on
a rooftop in San Diego yeah very
surrounded by a fake grass hut that's
very flammable I understand this is
their dream this was their dream and
you're one of us by the end of the week
oh you've been fired the math I've got
to get downstairs okay yeah there's a
whole stretching ritual I do that's nice
I have to prepare for a big guest we
have so many surprises great cold-open
you're gonna want to see that this is
exciting I like you guys wait I don't
really mean what I said well I'm just
going with it you guys are good guys
thank you for being here and for Conan
360 these guys are keeping it real is
that something people still yeah I say
that sometime I'm in my late 70s so I'd
have no idea I'm gonna drift off that
way now okay
I'm gonna go downstairs they actually
true story we got off on the wrong floor
and I walked like nine flights up to get
here yeah and I think I'm gonna throw up
so I'm gonna go do that now
that's great seeing you let's all move
again let's watch gonna throw up in 360
put those VR goggles on right now medium
get better than this it really doesn't
you guys should never stop at any moment
you should constantly
they do have an electric shock collar on
us if we do startle all right guys I
will see you later
with you during the week yes we got some
fun surprises coming up thank you thank
you code and peace out is that 70s
nothing that shirt going out mannequin
brother Conan O'Brien okay and he's just
wandering into traffic
yeah and that was nope you could easily
die yeah yeah yeah there's nothing but
ground if you see the fire marshal order
an uber for him that way to thin blue
tarps keeping people on the roof well if
you guys thought that we snuck up here
to do this now that just verified it
yeah everything what you're gonna see on
this show we're gonna be checking in
with all these different cams that are
around Christian be in the lobby yeah
they're playing games we're gonna have
guests on this show and right now I
lobby right there playing games out
talking to people as they come in some
people will win some prizes right take
it to the artists entrance in the alley
that's where all the famous people come
in to talk to other people that are
famous and they'll be going crazy and
now we're going to take a look at the
theater right now
oh you can see producers buzzing around
and getting the stage all mocked up for
Conan like a very slick dealership he
likes the floor slippery likes to slide
around and maybe get some insurance
money from the haunted Spreckels theater
and back to our cab so this is the one
that that's at our home base and right
now I want to show you guys highlight
from last year yeah this was this is the
the Suicide Squad cast entering from the
backstage and a little bit of 360 video
that you'll probably see it on some of
the show so let's start that right now
this is the Suicide Squad cast entering
in 360 let's go all right you guys ready
for suicides boy
landing the room in the castle Suicide
Squad that's gonna
[Applause]
[Music]
and that was a clip from last year that
was about 45 minutes of Will Smith just
doing this I also want to endures to you
guys that we are live streaming so you
can chat with us on the show we have
tablets in our hands to send your
questions for any guests that we have on
the show and a lot of the games are
gonna be helped with too so make sure
you help us out on the chats coning 360
calm right now we are very excited to
bring on our special guests legends in
the comic-con world the creators of
Harley Quinn who thank God Paul Dini
Amanda Connor and Jimmy palamino guys
welcome to the stage at a 360 they've
already seen you lurking in the corner
hey how are you guys Tommy addy I've
always wanted to have Apollo me know and
now I have so I called you Pellegrino I
usually get any yes tall drink of water
[Laughter]
Paul I just want a huge fan - Quinn
you're the co-creator of such a conic
character and here at comic-con you've
seemed a lot of people cosplaying what
does it feel like to see people dressed
up as a character that you created it's
it's surreal and it's a lot of fun
you know I a lot of times I'll look over
this sea of EDS and there are just all
these mallets and baseball bats and I'll
know that there's a different Harley
under each one whether it's DC superhero
girls or the comic book or the Bruce
Timm model it's it's it's Harley
polluted actually there is something
here called Harley Palooza
and I actually give away triple candy -
Harley's that come to my house for
Halloween yeah I got a couple of dads
dressed as Harley's and like the bite
yeah yeah they all get into the spirit
so she's become like Peter Pan anybody
can be Harley BR house at Halloween
we only give double candy okay obviously
yours a better place to go think about
toothbrushes toothbrush soap bars are so
pennies in a bag of apples pennies in a
sock so you guys you guys get to write
and animate these comics now and Harley
Quinn is such a fun character especially
in the DC Universe there's a little more
serious character with like Wonder Woman
what's it been like to write for Harley
Quinn it's been a blast yeah she's so
fun
she's ridiculously fun yeah it's nice to
be on a book that somebody reads to with
farang so that was pretty exciting dude
she's like other candy besides lollipops
no I'm a first-time comic on gold never
been before so what would your advice be
from me yeah yeah you can't do it all
it's impossible yes you got to really
pick what you want to do and like go and
wait in the line for whatever that is I
would say hydrate too and in shoes that
you can walk around easily and that's
yeah and don't buy anything til Sunday
yeah because they need to get rid of all
that stuff on Sunday Sunday is a day to
shop I'm trying to buy a bunch of pop-up
tables on the convention room floor yeah
national smell your dogs won the dog
whisperer man that's right and I watched
that episode and I know he ain't got
nothing to do harder Quinn yeah chill
chat room knows but is your dog doing
well no they're both dead
I mean
away from the edge of the building we
love him yeah yeah there they they
improved a lot they did and they're and
they're gone we now have pixie in the
tank they're doing great pixie in the
tank pixie in the tank nice but it was
really fun doing the dog whisperer
Cesar was great and do so we had a lot
of behavior problems you know snap right
up after that so the dogs on the show
they really love those credits rolling
that is like the comic book ending the
dogs are now dead did you do that thing
that Cesar tells you to do did you yeah
we did you know I mean we well what
happened was I would make excuses
produce it would be like you know he's
he's scared he's frightened and suzer
said no your talks a jerk you're scared
you're frightened that's that's why you
look you let it as 16 pound dog boss you
around right it's like it's true no I
got a question for you have you ever
made a character like in the beginning
as you're like creating it you like this
is gonna be dope and then when you
finish you like nah yeah like the
majority of them are just like no look
you know there they are for one and a
half comics and then like every once in
a while one hits or what happens is like
you're starting out in the business so
you'll take any work they give you right
and then they give you the worst
character and then they tell you by the
way it's gonna get cancelled in four
issues have fun so you're like alright
well I can eat for like four months
but I got to do work on the worst
character known to man so got a question
coming in from the chat this is Beth
from Minnesota she's for Paul Dini yes
we said it right just saying people's
name right like after thank you for
making my childhood great with the
Batman animated series I understand that
was the first time that Harley Quinn was
introduced right it wasn't supposed to
be a as a one-shot character yeah I
wrote a script called Joker's favor and
I Joker needed some hench have some
hench people in the gang and I thought
wouldn't it be fun to do kind of a
callback to the characters in the 60s
show where they had like a gun mall
or a henchgirl and I also thought
wouldn't be funny if she just gets
laughs than the Joker gets angry at her
because her jokes are better than his
yeah I just thought of her as a sort of
snappy 1940's type of screwball blonde
and and it it just sort of took off from
there Arleen Sorkin did a great voice
Bruce Timm did a terrific model and
everything just sort of you know came
together and we had a character that the
animators really wanted to bring back I
did hardly Stark and she was on Days of
Our Lives as yes as a clown in that show
that was like some of the inspiration
yeah she had she had been on that show a
couple of years before we came up with
Harley and either
I caught a rerun or I think she'd given
me like a tape of some of her
performances yeah we were for instance
college and I was watching I was
homesick and I was watching it one day
and I was like that's a fun you know
that that gesture out that that's sort
of fun and that was right around the
time that Harley was kind of you know
germinating in my head so it all kind of
came together that's great and now
there's dads all across the Midwest
dressing is that yes Halloween yes
that's right um and I know you and you
had something exciting to happen to you
or some of your artwork is featured on a
certain CBS show oh yeah that was a
while ago yeah yeah Wikipedia is putting
that up real high oh wait I'm gonna have
to excuse myself now to go down to the
alley and handle some fans wrangle them
put them in some chokehold
it was great to talk to y'all and let me
know how it goes baby yeah so that was
cool to see your artwork yeah it was
know we could say Big Bang Theory I'm
just tried out for the pilot and yeah
when they asked me I was like so like oh
my god great I love that show so much I
love it
yeah something not something you would
draw which is a like woman on a chain
yeah yeah yeah I don't always do it but
yeah it was so much fun it was a thrill
to see it yeah and interesting do you
have a special drawing oh I do I do have
yeah
it's probably on page 94 of that so
we'll just hold for eleven minutes okay
this is uh a special drawing you did
just for the Conan show this is Conan -
perfect Quinn yes and you know it's
amazing what you can find when I craft
oh absolutely there you go um when you
when you google image search
shirtless Conan because it was kind out
what is what color his chest hair what
color is Chester I thought those were
bees for a second the head drapes
neither one of them has ever looked
better please please do just that so
much for joining us here at the conan
360 live show a few plugs please follow
paul at paul underscore Dini
on Twitter and Amanda Rance a lot which
I really don't I'm a terrible tweeter
terrible to me there's just like a
period sometime yeah I think I tweet
like four times a year and that's J
there's my redemption meeting Tommy ah
tea there'll be a rosebud moment when
you're dying call me honey that's your
new name at home by the way hey mr.
Powell Palomino uh okay thank you guys
so much and we're gonna cut to the alley
right now where where some of the cast
is arriving let's go ahead and take a
look at that thank you guys so much
[Applause]
[Music]
guys we are seeing a live stream right
now from the alley where the cast of
bright is arriving we had a lot of fans
down there that have been lined up since
yesterday very excited this is this is
an exclusive look at the cast arriving
we can see people walking in right now
we got fans cheering got phones up we
got someone and down there
this is again the cast of bright that
you're seeing arrived on the conan 360
live show presented by AT&T
we got Will Smith just walking by that's
very right he's running in there this is
very exciting Will Smith famously last
year at the Conan show jumped across the
barricades and said hello to fans such a
great his fans again we're watching the
cast of bright starring Will Smith Joel
Edgington and I O'Meara peace and
directed director David I ear very
exciting movie that's coming out in
Netflix in December we can see a lot of
fans a lot of excitement down there as
the cast of bright is arriving and we
got more coming up right here on the
conan 360 live pre-show so just real
quick who's on the show tonight
conan has the cast of bright that's Will
Smith Joe Edgington
Naomi repeats and director David a year
this is all happening at 11:00 10:00
central and of course he's got the cast
of supernatural it's Jared and Jensen
the supernatural is a credible fan
favorite here at Comic Con it shows been
on for which Michael by 18 years and
there's a lot of fans that have been out
there which might be the earliest fans
have seen out there were fans for
Supernatural everyone's very excited and
their moms are very impatient waiting in
the van
this is a really cool behind-the-scenes
look of this is where all the guests
yeah we're drivin we're gonna be
checking there but this Pam all night as
these uh well I guess all day as these
guests arrive so you guys can see him
first right now I'm gonna check down
with Chris who's gonna play as a game
with some very excited audience member
again that's the conan 360 live pre-show
presented by AT&T and Conan and Chris is
gonna play some games that are gonna
surprise delight some fans we have you
down there in the lobby for some games
or we have you down at that artist
entrance actually well we are doing
exactly what we promised we are throwing
two cameras we don't have up yet all
right Mike so we're gonna go to Kristen
a little bit who's at the artists
entrance maybe catch one of these cast
members coming in they're rushing over
from Comic Con Comic Cons about four
blocks away from us and the streets are
just packed with fans we're out right
now with the cast of brightest coming in
and Will Smith is just rocked in right
now you know to me and all these fans
are going crazy you can see everybody
holding up their phones and all that
what's going on man Mido he gave me the
black man salute and that was solid you
know I must i'ma remember that for times
sake you know I may hear and have time
to roll in so we're gonna wait for more
people to come in but what we do we're
gonna play some games with some fans and
get them some tickets to the show but we
got out we got out we got our bags here
we ready to do this y'all who else is
coming in here I don't know
yeah so as soon as the fans get all
their pictures and all the stuff signed
we're gonna talk to him again some
tickets inside the show real fast
we got joel edgerton here right now
signing signed a bunch of fans toughest
subs oh how you doing
we got a lot of back Pat's and waves
going on for me right now we're gonna
talk to I one of the fans how y'all
doing today
Courtney Courtney were you able to get
some sign oh not yet no but you got a
bunch of pictures a couple I got a video
okay wait if you're ready to win some
tickets to go see the show I got a game
we can play if you're ready to play I'm
so down you so down you sure yes all
right I this game is called two things
that are real one that is not real
all right so I'm gonna give you two
movie quotes that are actually real and
then I'm gonna make up one from my life
and you have to figure out which one is
the one that's from my life are you
ready for this I'm ready you've got all
the rules yes all right hey there is
right and wrong in the universe and the
distinction is not hard to make that's a
B put that down I told you never to
touch that I'm a superhero
see some men aren't looking for
something logical some men and just just
want to watch the world burn a beer see
which one is fake B B that's right
that's from my mama my mama said that
when I touch a pot of greens all right
now do you recognize any of those other
quotes definitely you are definitely
right what you have just want is a bag
of swag
[Music]
and to show you what's in here
we got a mug with tickets to the show
tonight we got a bag within a bag we got
us some blankets but in a hat that says
Conan so you go ahead and take this are
you gonna come with us how is this
working this is this is so live we don't
know what's going on right now but you
definitely want all it is a McGinnis to
you and wait
we are surprising into lighting fans all
over with tickets to see the show
tonight the Conan show for sure and
we're gonna wait for more people to show
up but we're gonna play another game
unless somebody else win some tickets as
well let's see who is let's see who no
one's making noise there we go ha above
you above you're pointing at each other
ah look at this love that's real love
one of you kids just one of you is do
you okay you understand the rules of the
game yes what's your name Jill Jill
where you from Detroit Detroit oh yeah I
see you I'll see y'all Detroit okay here
we go
hey it doesn't matter who we are what
matters is our plan that's a B Only
Fools are heroes because you never know
when some lunatic will come with a
sadistic choice that's a long one and
never see another number C and C you
ain't never go into space put that away
see see that's right that was my dad
I wanted to be an astronaut he was like
you ain't never go into space he was
right I've never been there since now do
you remember the two of course I gave
you before I'll give it to you again if
you can name where they're from it
doesn't matter who we are what matters
is our plan and Only Fools are heroes
because you never know when the some
lunatic will come with a sadistic choice
oh no but I'm still gonna let you win
[Music]
[Applause]
here you go with a bag of swag it's two
tickets to the Conan show are you happy
yes thank you we are killing it right
now delivering happiness to everybody oh
oh y'all over there Oh y'all over there
are y'all people that's awesome
can y'all see me over there go away over
here like that yeah I think we can
what's going on y'all how are you your
name's Jeanette Jeanette just called me
over like a gangster y'all not making
any noise I'm sitting over here just
calm okay Jeanette do you know what the
game is all right the game is basically
two truths and a lie I'll give you two
movie quotes that are real and one that
I definitely made up out of my butt okay
and if you can guess the one that's fake
you might be able to win some tickets
right we're gonna do this real fast
because they told me to wrap it up
that's how real I keep it people all
right you ready for this you better be
ready for this all right
hey if you Cage the Beast the Beast will
get angry be a dog is a dog no matter
who it is attack see freedom is life's
great lie once you accept that you in
your heart you will know peace a B or C
hey it's a fake one which which one is
the fake one ah you're right
you guys make no noise make some noise
for them
thanks Chris everything looks super
exciting down there this whole building
is just surrounded by fans and this is a
huge event just the Conan show coming to
comic-con if you just feel that energy
around this building again you're
watching the conan 360 live pre-show I'm
your host Moses storm and none of this
would be possible without our friends at
AT&T and presented by AT&T I want to
show you guys some highlights from last
year's Conan show at comic-con let's
take a look at this thanks for joining
us we are here with Jorge Lasky Jordan
say hello to everybody hi I'm Jordan
shlonsky hello and today we are here in
Jordan's office and we're gonna be
Jordans gonna be taking your questions
some fan questions that we got from both
Twitter and Facebook so Jordan first of
all could you kind of take us around
your office a little bit this is it this
is where you spend your day what's what
is all this stuff what what do you what
do you have here this is my office and I
think you'll find it a dynamic
environment I'm excited to be here I'm
excited you're in it you do come into my
office often for personal reasons you
sit in that very chair and you confess
your sins that's in your various
adventures it's worth noting that while
you and I have never appeared on camera
before we have obviously known each
other for many years and we have had
many adventures off-camera together yes
fair to say but for example have you and
I ever sat in the private VIP room at
the ESPN Zone in New York have we ever
had dinner next to Natalie Portman
without you knowing without me knowing
as a Star Wars yes we have we have done
that we have done both those things we
have gone to parties together that's
true yeah we have I don't know how many
years it's been I'm gonna guess you've
been around for about 16 years that's
correct you are at the remote shoot of
the Westminster Dog Show part three I
believe that's true
thanks to you by the way as you in a
sense that was a watershed moment in
your career absolutely so excited to be
here I'm excited that you're in my
office I approach this from a very
humble attitude
I find it hard to believe that people
have questions about me and are
curiously I mean anyway nevertheless you
assure me they do and I'm happy to
answer them for what it's worth
yes this is my office it is a dynamic
environment such as the human minds I
don't know where you want to start wait
I just have a question before we begin
what what is all this why are these
things what is all this here you I see
that a couch back there why do you have
so many boxes in here well you know
that's a very simple question with a
very complex answer each box has its own
story okay has its own story I can tell
you this whenever someone on staff needs
a bag you can bet that they come here
whoa there we go field producer Jason
shilling me is in here almost nightly
asking for a bag there we go in fact
I've got a bag in every size that you
might want I've got large grocery style
bags and I've got smaller shopping bags
I've got stylish one if you're going out
on the town whatever you need in fact I
have a large array bag here from the
famous French patisserie known for their
macarons but not only macarons
in fact the lingerie location in Soho in
New York is my favorite spot for a
European style breakfast when I'm in New
York now the European style breakfast
that I'm familiar with is generally for
example in Italy known as a cappuccino
brioche which is a cappuccino which is a
espresso shot with milk and then a
brioche some kind of pastry it's usually
a croissant it could be anything I like
a pie no Chocolat now of course it's
very difficult to make those pastries
and have them fresh
but Lodger a to me is one of the best in
the United States Wow it's a
transporting experience I recommend you
go to the one if in New York however the
one downtown in Soho is my favorite and
of course there are a lot to raise all
over the world the Parisians will tell
you that the originals are in Paris
since the year 1862 according to this
bag I have a question when you you
obviously have you are a collector of
experiences and restaurants and great
things like that how do you know when
you say like like this place is a
transporting experience does that happen
the first time you go do you know
immediately or is it upon return visits
slowly you're like oh this place is
living up to my expectations like like
it for something for you to recommend a
place to go
do you have to have been there a number
of times so it's consistent that's a
great question in fact for me to connect
with a place it's often instant and they
say that people know who they're
attracted to instantly and for me it
works the same way with not only people
but with environments as well I feel
like sometimes I connect instantly on a
spiritual level if you will on an
energetic level maybe it's a similar
wavelength or other resonance with an
environment that I'm in and I've gone
into restaurants and known that I love
that restaurants within seconds before I
even realize what was on the menu
because you connect with the place Wow
all right wow it's immediate its
immediate and in fact not only do I walk
into a restaurant and feel a connection
but the choice of where I sit is in fact
very important there are horrible tables
and there are good tables and the the
good ones are not necessarily what you
might think for me I prefer a table
against a wall I don't like to be in the
center of the restaurant and you like to
observe all that's before you I like
it's a it's a form of protection in fact
evolutionary protection if there's a
wall against you you know that nobody
else is behind you and in fact when you
do a lot of personality tests they will
ask you questions like that doesn't
matter to you where you sit in a
restaurant and if so where do you choose
to sit interesting and do you what is
your opinion in terms of primes of proc
pinyin in terms of proximity to the key
that of course was not a highlight
presented by AT&T of last year's show
that was associate producer Jordan
slansky who has zero highlights in his
life I'm pretty sure that man is so
boring when he shuffles off this mortal
coil not even his own life will flash
before it'll just be error 404 you guys
aren't done watching the conan 360 live
show I'm your host Moses storm right now
we're gonna join my correspondent who is
down in the lobby to play some games
with some fans presented by AT&T and
he's get a surprise and delight them
with some prizes Chris do I got you down
in the lobby he's a play build a better
superhero what's going on yeah I'm in
the lobby because I have multiple
locations I'm at we have that money
all right we're here with a couple of
guests couple fans of comic-con and
they're gonna play a game with me called
build a better hero all right what I
want to do is I'm gonna go to the chat
and I'm gonna get a name of a new
superhero that doesn't exist like boobie
man or that's good enough so and they
will have 30 seconds to dress me up as
that superhero and they'll have to tell
me the origin story and the super power
of this new superhero that does not
exist
do y'all ready for that who wants to go
first
Oh sold you out all right come on around
here man let's play yeah yeah yeah
come on around there dog with this plate
oh good good job ladies way to sell out
the man quick I like that about you
all right now what's your name sir Corey
Corey solid name where you from San
Diego San Diego so you have to try
before and what's your favorite thing
about comic-con this this right here my
man oh you already own it man hold on
wait one second all right we're gonna go
to the chat right now and i'ma pick a
name that they've that the chat is
giving us all right this is y'all
thought if it sucks there we go from
Julie squid man okay squid man is your
hero you have 30 seconds or so I'm not
counting here we go go
put the put the mic under my mask okay
there we go
hey alright Chad how do I look yeah now
what now what is my origin story you're
born in the ocean that's it I'm just
born in the oh no you're the fastest
ocean creature that anyone's ever seen
so you try to put on the gloves and the
mask and the eyeglasses but you were
just too fast they fell off but then you
found the toys and then now you're squid
man that sounds real cool guy
what's my superpower speed I have super
speed I'm very ugly and I have a glove
that doesn't fit
I am squid man playa alright got alright
guys now this is for the chat chat room
on a scale of 1 to what the heck am I
looking at what do you rate them they
got a 6 let me check with the chatroom
you know what man for your creativity
I'm gonna go ahead and give you a sweat
bag brother you earned it enjoy
comic-con and I'm going to take this off
because it's crazy I feel like I'm being
born again out of this mass that is
craziness
i'ma say here that like this is normal
real normal all right ladies any many
mighty come on we got the next one
coming these are really tight these are
like condoms keep all that all right
everything's going all right you guys
how are you awesome
say it again I'm awesome good putting
this all right now what's your name
Jennifer Jennifer
now uh where you from San Diego that's
dope and what is your favorite thing
about comic-con it's all the panel's I
love sitting in there for a day and
listen all the entertainers talk yeah oh
that has to be so much fun right
who's who's affair is there anyone that
you're looking like real for to Doctor
Who Doctor Who panel I don't blame you
at all now you got you got the UH you
know how to game works right yeah okay
well I'm gonna go to the chat see who
they pick and see if you can win some
stuff the lock up from Chris The
Lonesome Dove the Lonesome Dove is your
superhero are you ready ready go
Oh she quit on her own time and that was
way longer than 30 seconds I'm sure but
I wasn't counting cuz it was awesome
look at me player I look like a bandit
that that saves strip clubs across
America and this is the best thing the
lonesome dove all right now the lump
sums up what is my origin story when you
were growing up you watched your dad die
and you want to avenge him so you got
the mask because you didn't want anyone
no you're perfect you're identity of
course not and then you just started
going avenging people mama i avenged all
the time what I do daily I avenge
alright now what is my superpower um
your superpower is your vision cuz you
can spot anybody out of a crowd and you
know what they did wrong oh so a
lonesome dove can avenge and he spots
things cuz he's a nosy man I like that a
lot man alright chat The Lonesome Dove
what did you give it one two I feel cool
as hell
they're taking way too long
someone go to you what are you what do
you think of this y'all she even a whole
ten from your competition I feel great
in this so I'm gonna go give you a ten
and a bag of swag you ready to go go
ahead take your bag of swag and thank
you for playing thank you for playing
imma shoot you guys right now - Moses
Moses what's it looking like up there
hey Chris how's it goin I really hope
you keep that on
and people have screen grabs of that cuz
that is embarrassing what a fun game
that is guys you're watching the conan
360 live pre-show presented by AT&T and
now we're gonna give a chance to look at
the highlights from last year's
comic-con Show with Conan I can promise
you this will not be Jordan let's see
that
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so he's young right okay
I want to do the Kessel run in 1646 mom
no no no no I'm Han Solo han Solo hey
I'm fella just like he's on his way to
do errands or whatever
I'm also Batman
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the conan 360
pre-show I'm joined right now very
exciting by the some of the writers from
Conan Todd Levin and Jesse Glasgow how
is it the truth oh my gosh Joe yeah I
think you got her name wrong
I felt like as soon as it came out of
your mouth you weren't sure so you guys
get to travel a lot with this show
you've been on the road with this show
before
very well oiled machine how does being a
Comic Con differ from some of the other
places that you've been like New York
San Francisco the show's been more
Chipotle's so many more well I mean
you're also a you know usually when we
go to another town there's not this
enormous event happening right around
you where you're dropped in the middle
of this other like massive pop cultural
event so it's always a little it's kind
of crazy at Comic Con for that reason
they're just always people walking
around in costume and stuffing and
they're looking at us like what are you
guys doing here right why would you come
here this week yeah have you seen any
conan cosplays around yeah some some
other pale skinny people right I think
yeah it's early on right cuz the
convention doesn't start until tomorrow
the cert time to like Thursday like the
die-hard people that are really into
dressing up are here they're already
here they got through my hotel lobby
okay I think these corner shows it's
always like it feels like at the
comic-con shows you guys do really big
sketches and and set pieces yeah do you
guys have we do a lot of stuff like that
like yeah like do you have something
that that you may be written that was
like a big set piece that maybe got cut
that was something that you liked for
comic-con yeah I getting it by 10 I can
think of one I can definitely think of
one
first year that got cut that was it was
like an idea that I really liked but it
just was executed it just was too hard
to do I think it was the idea was that
we had an acapella group called Hull
capella that was okay it was an all hulk
acapella group so which was like really
funny to me on paper but then you have
to cast for do to look like the hulk but
can also sing acapella
and harmonize mean is casting breakdown
yes someone who looks like hulk without
makeup
yeah will provide it also has a
beautiful singing has a rifle and yeah
someone who could be like tenor and
ultimately they have to be able to
harmonize so it so it did not work how
far did you get process was it like
writing the casting breakdown no no no
it was getting bodybuilders covered in
green makeup out in front of the
building wearing straw burgers and
singing bicycle built for two and this
was cut yeah so they were out there
watch tonight I finally made it yeah ten
years in LA yeah for the role of a
lifetime yeah the most shredded tenor
and they didn't get on TV yeah I mean it
was like two hours in makeup for each of
them therefore guys they did still get
paid but I never think about that way I
always just think about the humiliation
the bits that got cut in the exact
dollar about how much how much basically
a money laundering scheme I did figure
that it's like why are we doing a show
on the roof this year yes yeah I'm not
sure why you're just burning piles of
cash over there but oh that is a
tendency to keep the lights on we ran
out of money for dirty energy um no I
mean I I can't think of anything cuz to
be honest this year is the first year
I've really had some good stuff in the
show usually because comic-con I would
say is maybe not my wheelhouse yeah
quite as much so my my pitches for like
what if we got the cast of 9 to 5 the
musical
um spam a lot that natto huge right yeah
I bet we're not as excited about that
here so but I have some good stuff
hopefully lineup is here
talk to me after this year shows and
then I'll tell you what no I think like
a lot of it I just from watching the
show like a lot of the writers end up in
the sketch is it saves money right it
kind of does its respond to who's the
most reluctant writer on the show to be
in the sketches Gordo
yeah yeah Gordo only plays the
masturbating bear so he Michael Gordon
in a bear costume yeah but he does
masturbate in front of people which is
the only bit that's been brought over
from the old show just about yeah right
yeah I think this class well celebrity
surveys yeah try I'm trying they're
coupled SP I think the celebrity surveys
is a desk piece as a Knoll that's an old
one but but yeah as far as characters
it's pretty much just the masturbating
bear and trying to baby bear yeah that's
I was forbidden from watchin the show
growing up my mom saw one episode
because of that yeah she said she's not
wrong on the entertainment part you a
favorite character on the show I mean my
favorite character worked on is I think
wiki bear I used to I used to write that
with another writer named Brian stack
super funny and he did the he did the
voice of a two and it was this it was
based on a real thing that I'd seen an
article on it was a like a little
talking teddy bear yeah that kids could
ask questions too and it was connected
to the Internet and it would somehow
feed you that answer from Wikipedia for
which whatever your question was so we
would have we had this like you know
animated bear sitting on Conan's desk in
Conan would ask it questions like very
kind of kitty questions cute things and
it would answer them and then it would
segue the answer into something like
just horrifying yeah
yeah so it always goes to genocide yeah
it was always like you're about a serial
killer or a famous massacre and it was
super upbeat it was just always always
upbeat
oh the bear present yeah are you guys
comic fans are you just saying steer
clear of that if there's so much to do
on the show I mean I mean I'm not a into
comics really I love Game of Thrones
yeah me too
so there's I find yeah there's a lot
here for me I will say when I saw Wonder
Woman I was like I get it I get why kids
little boys like superheroes like this
is awesome
this she's kicking so many asses and you
know that really I me where I was like
oh this yeah this is really fun yeah but
it took is there I guess you're looking
forward to that's on the show
yeah it was one we're now allowed to say
I think right well there's one show that
I'm really looking forward to but we're
not allowed to say Mauro's on it
tomorrow she'll joel edgerton fan i'll
say it yeah yeah yeah underrated right
he looks a lot like Conan - I said that
to other people and they're like no I
don't see it he looks like a buff Conan
yeah yeah he does like it like like God
finished making Conan was the punch oh
yeah let's just put a pin in this yeah
so writers have nothing more than
playing very dumb games so we're gonna
bring Chris on for a very lovely game of
cornhole everyone's favorite game from
1944 yep writers to play
play Hulk smash cornhole baby that's
right we have a very heavy-handed
comic-con twist on the and are these
supposed to make it harder yeah like I
don't need them then I don't want to
that's oh you got it you gotta do on
this point oh that baby yeah went out
and spent most of their Tuesday night
yeah looking yeah so we got the non
royalty-free version of Hulk hands but
they're open fisted they're not too used
to be little trampolines but they were
too sad so basically what we figured out
is you would stand somewhere here that
first blue one is worth five points and
then the second one is worth 10 points
oh yeah four bags each okay yeah in the
hole right in the hole okay no three
there we go
everyone gets three what are you guys
usually doing it this time
overhand I mean didn't work but it was
nice three and exactly as fun and that
means Todd is the winner yes that means
Todd gets to move on to the next round
today oh great they're 10 more people
get to play after this oh right who's
gonna give you an exclusive tour of his
office let's go hey welcome to the 360
live pre-show Conan O'Brien here and
this is cool you are inside my personal
office at Warner Brothers this is where
the magic happens and by magic I mean
this is where I sit and I'm depressed
and hate myself for a huge period of
time before the show let me show you
around it's pretty cool we've got a nice
office here here's my door I have an old
typewriter and I typed Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address on it a couple years
ago and put it up one of the greatest
speeches of all time and then I
pretended to sign it a Lincoln people
get impressed but it's not Lincoln's
signature it's mine I got some cool
mementos here some really nice letters
from people that have worked with me
look at this isn't this cool this is
something Andy Richter gave me it's
shows you the skeleton of the Pillsbury
Doughboy isn't that cool he gave that to
me like five years ago and I absolutely
love it I've never looked at the
Pillsbury Doughboy the same way again
I've got some Jameson's here I don't
drink hard alcohol but I like having it
so I look like a sort of tough guy this
is my podium right here where I go over
monologue jokes or go over scripts
during the day these are various little
solutions that I spray on my glasses
ah this is my BlueCross BlueShield
health card oh here's something cool
forget that happened this is a button
check this out this is really cool this
automatically closes the door I love
this hey sonic can I talk to you for a
second Sona it's my assistant sauna I
forget it it gets me every time here's a
cool phone that I got when I was in
Armenia with Sona we did in Armenia
travel show and I bought this phone when
I was there and it's got Russian
lettering on it because of course Russia
controlled Armenia back then
here are some boots I got on my neck
ciccone
trip from former President Vicente Fox
no effing wall referring of course to
Trump's proposed border wall and these
are cool boots I've got a bust of John F
Kennedy there another Irishman from
Brookline Massachusetts I love my
American presidents there's harry s
truman personally signed by harry s
truman there's my California Republic
flag right here this is where we write
down who's gonna be on the show this
week and what comedies planned as you
can see we're having a little bit of a
rough patch right now just kidding this
is a dark week so that's why that's
clear a fan-made this you may have seen
this before I made it completely out of
scrap metal it's a little Conan one of
the most creative things I ever seen
Andrew Smith made this shout out to
Andrew Smith that's absolutely beautiful
and actually what my real skeleton looks
like I've got this is cool this is uh
the pins from last year's comic-con
someone put these in plastic and gave
them to me and so I keep those this is a
map of the United States and then of
course a map of the world most evil
people like myself love a map of the
world Stalin had one and just pretty
much anyone who wants to take over the
world has maps of the world that's me
and I want to spread my form of comedy
throughout the region takes us back to
this area right here this is a quick
check look at this this is a lot of
Pedialyte a couple days ago I was
vomiting violently because of a stomach
bug and I had them go get me Pedialyte I
said Sona
get me some Pedialyte she bought me like
nine giant bottles of Pedialyte I had to
get through the show it wasn't easy but
I got through the show it didn't vomit
once but I had a bucket under the desk
in case I had to that's the kind of
dedication I have and I love this right
here I also got this in Armenia it's an
old Russian like way of telling what day
and date it is I love I just love stuff
like this you know simple low-tech this
was the original
Apple watch when they first came out
with it is what it looked like and uh oh
I think them at a time someone's trying
to get in here pretty much that's my
office I hope you enjoyed it 360 techno
go to pod I don't know welcome back to
the conan 360 live a pre-show back up
here with chris red finally made it back
man i did you know i did a tour the
building so a lot of things we learned
about a lot man how's that artist intro
oh damn that artists that artist
entryway it teaches me a lot about life
it teaches me that when will sniffers
around you barely matter and the games
were so fun man we i was able to give
some people tickets for playing the game
to troops in aloha basic and man people
know their movie quotes and kind of
don't and my family does also trick
almost tricked one of them which was
great instruction on what was the one it
was a dog as a dog attack cuz I ran up
with these guys long when I was 12 and
he was me and I was like please don't a
chill dog bite me and he was like a dog
the dog attack yeah I ran I got away
that you should attack he set the dog on
me because I was in his garden dog is a
dog attack he was a crazy person when
the cold opening of DOC the bounty
hunter no work was done he just did web
sociation from dog to dog how was that
he interviews me great yeah we had the
great cast of well dead zero cast we saw
maybe had critters of Harley Quinn they
were they were they were really fun a
very scary drawing of Conan on the show
yeah oh that's though I have to see that
later yeah yeah yes it'll be framed in
your dressing room and
yeah we got to see a backstage look and
then we got to talk to some of the
writers about some some a lot of money
that they've wasted just on the show
this show is burning money I love it me
and I have a new superhero the lonesome
Lonesome Dove they have become a to a
theater sit maybe yeah look for a DCC in
comics
hey y'all so much for joining yeah man
you know the back you know tomorrow 3:30
we're doing these live free shows all
week long I want to thank all of our
guests critters parley Quinn and the
writers of the comics and of course the
writers of the Conan show we're gonna
throw it onto this stage right now where
we're gonna color shows about to start
Kona shows but right now so we're
getting a look at that stage oh man
people on their feet here let me go
thank you guys so much for watching I'm
Moses storm I'm Chris red
[Music]
you